deutschland sei bereit einen hohen
wirtschaftlichen preis zu zahlen sagte
die bundes außenministerin an russlands
adresse beim blick auf die gasrechnung
sind sich viele bürger dann nicht mehr
ganz so sicher das leben wird deutlich
teurer
heizen einkaufen autofahren die
inflation ist weltweit zurück und wer
ist schuld putin die märkte die deutsche
klimapolitik die steuern steigen
wenigstens die löhne in diesem land
fragezeichen und gibt es irgendwann
wieder zinsen fürs ersparte
preisschock nach der pandemie was muss
die politik jetzt tun fragen wir uns und
diese gäste
annabel oelmann die
verbraucherschützerin sagt die höheren
preise überfordern viele menschen
henrike roßbach die journalisten stellt
fest der wohlstandsverlust hat die
mittelschicht erreicht
friedrich merz der cdu chef fordert
steuersenkungen bei benzin und diesel
das würde millionen pendler entlasten
katrin göring eckardt für die grünen
politikerin gilt nur mit grüner energie
wird strom zukünftig billiger
und christian lindner der
bundesfinanzminister sagt wir lassen die
menschen mit steigenden preisen nicht
allein sie sind zu gast bei maybrit
illner und die begünstige säure abend
sehr herzlich in der runde die inflation
ist zurück das leben wird teuer und
höher manche recht ungemütlich
daniel zetzsche arbeitet als hausmeister
teils selbstständig teils fest an einer
wiesbadener schule er merkt alles wird
teurer die einmalhandschuhe die sind das
doppelte teurer geworden da habe ich
früher für das päckchen 399 bezahlt und
bezahlt jetzt 97
preise steigen sein einkommen nicht
der familienvater muss sparen vor allem
beim benzin ist etwas gemerkt dass ich
vorher mal für 25 euro den voll gemacht
habe
mittlerweile kommt man an die 40 50 euro
an dann überlegt man auch mal privat mit
der familie wenn man mal ein
ausflugsziel anfangen möchte was ein
bisschen weiter ist das machen wir jetzt
mal nicht die inflation erreicht die
mitte der gesellschaft
energiekosten steigen drastisch plus
20,5 prozent
nahrungsmittel verteuerten sich um 5
prozent und dienstleistungen um drei
arbeiten halbtags bei jedem einkauf muss
sie mehr bezahlen
ganz klar die milchprodukte der
wocheneinkauf für uns vier personen lag
bei 120 130 euro und jetzt ganz klar bei
170 euro damit es bis zum monatsende
reicht versuchen sie alle kosten niedrig
zu halten
ich bringe es auch meinen kindern bei
dass wenn wir zum beispiel über lüften
das fenster aufmachen dann die heizung
runterdrehen dein fernseher zum beispiel
wenn wir dann auch nicht da sind dass
wir den standby ausschalten den stecker
ziehen
die zu tisch leben gut sagen sie aber
ihr lebensstandard ist in gefahr
geht es immer mehr menschen wie der
familie zollitsch das fragen wir uns und
fragen es annabel oelmann sie arbeitet
in und für die verbraucherzentrale in
bremen und mit ihr sind wir in bremen
jetzt verbunden pöhlmann gibt es immer
mehr menschen wie familien ja wirklich
also viele leiden durch corona schon
länger dass die kassen waren auch schon
knapper und jetzt kommt zusätzlich die
angst vor der inflation und die hohen
energiepreise das treibt viele wirklich
gerade auch mit angst vor an und sie
wissen nicht was sie tun sollen können
auch kleine mehrausgaben die familien da
schon in not bringen ja gerade wenn sie
früher schon die ganze zeit gekämpft und
gestrampelt haben ist natürlich der
kampf auch irgendwann verloren das heißt
viele sind noch nicht wieder bei dem
einkommensniveau vor krone sind
vielleicht noch in kurzarbeit oder haben
nebenjobs verloren mussten den jobs auf
gegen wegen homeschooling die
energiekosten zu hause sind gestiegen
wegen home office und homeschooling wir
sind mehr zu hause und ja das heißt
viele kämpfen schon lange seit zwei
jahren und wenn jetzt noch weitere
kosten obendrauf kommen kann es schnell
brenzlig werden wir sind hier in der
runde unter anderem heute bei uns die
journalistin hauptstadtstudio
korrespondentin der süddeutschen zeitung
vor rosbach die franzosen haben die
geldwerten übergezogen wenigstens zu
großen teilen und sind auf die straße
gegangen und haben demonstriert die
deutschen machen jetzt den gürtel enger
schnallen den gürtel enger und zahlen
die deutschen sind ja traditionell nicht
die streik und protestiere europameister
sozusagen das ist ja unter anderem auch
darin begründet dass für dieses
vielleicht ein bisschen weiter aber es
gibt ja keinen politischen streik in
deutschland sondern gestreikt wird ja
immer nur um dinge die tarifpartner
miteinander
klären können aber das ist in der
bevölkerung
spielt die sorge um die preise die sorge
um die lebenskosten und wie man damit
zurecht kommen soll nach diesen panini
an also ich glaube dass bekommt ja jeder
an seinem umfeld direkt mit und ich
glaube das wird eher noch mehr als
weniger werden christian lindner ist bei
uns allen der bundesfinanzminister um
die menschen die ganz wenig haben und
die einen zuschuss bekommen jetzt auch
von der regierung bekommen sollen nicht
gleich zuerst geredet um die reichen die
sich leisten können fünf prozent
inflation noch on top zu zahlen auch
nicht was ist mit den vielen menschen
dazwischen die wenig verdienen fleißig
arbeiten kriegen die gar nichts doch wir
müssen uns genau um die kümmern die
breite mitte unseres landes die menschen
die arbeiten die vielleicht in den
betrieb oder in das büro pendeln müssen
und die in besonderer weise jetzt
belastet sind durch die steigenden
preise wir werden ja vielleicht noch
sprechen darüber ob es eine dauerhafte
entwicklung ist oder eine die auch mit
der pandemie und anderen faktoren
zusammenhängt wir wollen jedenfalls in
diesem jahr die sogenannte eeg umlage
also eine umlage für die erneuerbaren
energien die auf die stromrechnung
aufgeschlagen wird kann das schaffen das
sind 6,6 milliarden euro und ich glaube
dass wir darüber hinaus auch tätig
werden müssen mal sehen was in diesem
jahr noch möglich ist mindestens in den
nächsten jahren muss gehandelt werden es
unterjährig mitten in einem jahr immer
nicht ganz einfach aber ich jedenfalls
wäre darüber bereit zu sprechen weitere
maßnahmen einzuladen über die könnten
wir hier diskutieren
katrin göring eckardt ist bei uns von
bündnis 90 die grünen es gibt nicht
wenige die sagen frau göring-eckardt
dass das eine grüne inflation sei
dagegen müssen sie sofort heftig
argumentieren es ist vielleicht jetzt
nicht die allererste frage aber an 7 wie
besorgt sind sie über diese
mischung aus corona spätfolgen aus
inflation aus kriegsangst aus einer
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung weltweit
kann man da und ob noch eine revolution
planen klima wende es ist ja eher anders
rum ihre sendung heißt ja was ist der
wohlstand in gefahr und der wohlstand
ist natürlich in gefahr wenn es so
weitergeht mit dem was wir glaube ich
fossile inflation nennen müssen weil es
hängt an den gaspreisen und da geht es
um geopolitik bei putin das gas
verknappt und es geht natürlich auch um
die preise und deswegen haben wir ganz
klar eine inflation eine
preisentwicklung die beruht auf den
fossilen zeitalter deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass zu verändern und dann mal
den wohlstand sichern will dann bedeutet
das eben ganz klar auf erneuerbare zu
setzen auf nachhaltigkeit zu setzen in
vielen bereichen aber das was sie
ansprechen ist ja noch was anderes ja
die sorge kann ich das eigentlich alles
jetzt schaffen wie viel stress ist also
irgendwann wird vielleicht grüne energie
dann auch preiswerte um ihren gedanken
zu folgen aber was machen verbraucher
bis dahin die die grüne energie ist ja
jetzt schon günstiger die eeg-umlage
fällt das hat christian lindner heute
gesagt wie der gegen uns nicht weiter
die erste hälfte ist schon möglich weil
er genau deswegen ist ja die frage was
passiert mit denen die sich wirklich
nicht leisten können das ist auf der
einen seite brauchen den
heizkostenzuschuss für diejenigen
unteren bereich wir brauchen auch nur
soforthilfe für kinder die in armut
leben in geringen einkommens
familienleben das muss sehr sehr schnell
passieren bis wir die
kindergrundsicherung mal haben wo das
alles sehr viel einfacher wird und wir
müssen natürlich auch wenn es darum geht
was ist beim co2 preis bei den gebäuden
sagen die sorgen wir dafür dass menschen
die dann am ende in wohnungen leben die
saniert sind wo die mieter und die
vermieter bezahlen müssen wie sorgen wir
dafür dass die eine entlastung reden
altenhilfe morgen ein großes paket und
das muss besonders aber denen helfen die
besonders darunter leiden und wir
brauchen die langfristperspektive mit
den günstigen energie
friedrich merz eine menge zu diskutieren
fraktionsvorsitzender cdu csu wie cdu
vorsitzender sie haben im herbst des
letzten jahres gesagt die inflation
trägt einen namen olaf scholz
in den usa gibt es auch eine inflation
von 75 prozent sogar wie sauber ist das
und hat nicht gerade die ganze becken
problem hätten also deswegen ist ganz
gut wenn wir mal kurzen augenblick über
die ursachen sprechen in dieser
preisentwicklung und wir müssen
vielleicht zunächst mal feststellen dass
sich auch eine ganze reihe von ökonomen
in deutschland richtig gehört haben auch
welche die hier am tisch gesessen haben
die uns gesagt haben das ist von kurzer
dauer schon im nächsten jahr sind wir da
wieder raus heute müssen wir sagen wir
werden da wahrscheinlich noch das ganze
jahr und darüber hinaus drin bleiben die
ursachen liegen sicherlich auch bei den
energiekosten aber wir haben eine
inflation die auch durch die verknappung
zum beispiel von bauteilen entsteht die
preise steigen ja auch bei autos bei
vielen anderen produkten die jetzt
knapper werden und wir haben zum dritten
eine inflation die im arbeitsmarkt
entsteht wir haben eine preis
lohnspirale ohne beteiligung der
tarifvertragsparteien die die
arbeitskosten werden höher weil wir
plötzlich durch die digitalisierung eine
veränderung unserer arbeitswelt haben
die wir wahrscheinlich erst im laufe des
jahres richtig sehen werden und dann
werden die familien die verbraucher in
den nächsten monaten möglicherweise zur
sommerpause ihre nun ihre
nebenkostenabrechnung bekommen aus ihren
wohnungen und ihren häusern und dann
werden wir preise sehen von 2000 euro
mehr als geplant weil es gegen die
oppositionsführer er frisch bestellte
vor es gibt zwei ebenen auf denen was
passieren kann die eine ebene ist die
europäische zentralbank die leider nicht
handelt anders als andere zentralbanken
müssen wir darüber sprechen die zweite
ebene ist die politische ebene das ist
die bundesregierung der bundestag die
etwas tun könnten wir haben in dieser
woche vorschläge gemacht zum beispiel
kalte progression zum beispiel die
steuerbelastung zu senken zum beispiel
die energiekosten zu senken die
mehrwertsteuer pendlerpauschale
anzuheben also wir wahr wir brauchen
wahrscheinlich jetzt eine mischung aus
mehreren elementen um diese preissenkung
auch zu erreichen ist wird schwierig
aber ich will mal zu frau göring-eckardt
sagen wenn die grünen und diese
regierung auf dem weg vorangehen den sie
planen im hinblick auf diese
energiewende oder auf das was sie sich
vorstellen auch mit grüner energie dann
kann es sein dass wir in fünf oder zehn
jahren wirklich preisgünstige grüne
energie haben aber bis dahin würden das
alles noch ziemlich teuer und insofern
sind die hoffnungen auf kurzfristige
änderung jedenfalls mindestens eine
klang war sehr begrenzt und fragen aber
jetzt frau immer noch mal wie sehr in
die fälle die sich bei ihnen melden frau
irgendwann die menschen die sich bei
ihnen melden wie sehr problematisieren
die eben die energiepreise
erstmal problematisieren sie das ganze
thema knappe kassen also sie kommen mit
verschiedensten problemen zu uns haben
sie die alte lebensversicherung kündigen
wollen die anschlussfinanzierung bei der
baufinanzierung nicht hinbekommen oder
aber die energieabrechnung vor sich
haben oder sogar angekündigten energie
vertrag haben es sind die
verschiedensten themen aber das thema
knappe kassen wir können es nicht mehr
zahlen wir wissen nicht wie wir das
wuppen sollen ist das dominante thema
bei den verbraucherinnen und
verbrauchern und gerade die
einkommensschwachen die ganz knapp über
transferleistungen sind die werden im
moment noch nicht gut mitgedacht und
gerade die brauchen natürlich massive
unterstützung gerade die kunden sind in
größenordnung auch über nacht aus ihren
störung und gasverträgen geflogen
darüber müssen wir unbedingt reden auch
wenn das jetzt mit einer also nicht mit
nur einer ursache zu erklären es ist es
natürlich ein wahnsinn wenn strom und
gaskunden plötzlich mitgeteilt bekommen
dass sie neukunden sind und
hundertprozentige aufschläge zu zahlen
haben wie viel haben sie das in ihren
berichten und sagen dass kunden das war
natürlich genau nachdem es passiert ist
im dezember letzten jahres der massive
ansturm bei uns die leute wussten gar
nicht wie ihnen geschehen ist viele
haben es auch gar nicht erst verstanden
weil es ja gar nicht von ihrem alten
anbieter erklärt bekommen haben sondern
im prinzip nur vom ersatz versorger die
information bekommen haben herzlich
willkommen jetzt sind sie bei uns und
die leute waren natürlich einerseits
schockiert dass es so passieren kann
dass es auch klares marktversagen
geschäftsmodelle sollten funktionieren
sollten auch so transparent und gut
beaufsichtigt sein dass so etwas
natürlich gar nicht passieren kann dass
man die kunden mal eben vor die tür
setzt die leute müssen jetzt auch
handeln müssen sich darum kümmern
entweder aus der ersatzversorgung
rauszukommen aber auf jeden fall auch
die richtigen vollmachten auszugeben
ansonsten droht da auch schnell wieder
die stromsperre falls sie nicht an den
richtigen anbieter zahlen und das mag
man sich jetzt auch nicht so richtig
vorstellen herr lindner in dieser
situation kann und muss der staat
eigentlich was tun da sind billiger
anbieten quasi in einen markt geschoben
worden damit es einen größeren
wettbewerb gibt es ist nachvollziehbar
und glücklich aber offensichtlich hat
niemand überprüft ob die überhaupt
geschäftsfähig sind naja das ist die
liberalisierung des strommarkts und man
darf dankbar sein dass es
verbraucherschützerin und
verbraucherschützer gibt die jetzt auch
darüber informieren auf was wir als
stromkunden und stromkunden zu achten
haben und darüber hinaus wird jetzt ein
gespräch zu führen sein und die
bundesregierung hat das bereits
aufgenommen mit den stromanbietern
insbesondere auch mit denjenigen die die
grundversorgung liefern dass hier auch
wirklich eine faire preisgestaltung
stattfindet das ist der markt dann kommt
der bereich des staates haben wir
jetzt mehrere schon gesagt wir bauen die
energieversorgung um das ist übrigens in
deutschland ja
einvernehmlich also die energie
versorgung klimaneutral zu gestalten ist
ein ziel aller parteien schon die
vorgängerregierung hat das ziel 2045
ausgegeben das muss schnell gelingen wir
brauchen auch mehr versorgungssicherheit
indem wir andere energie
lieferanten öffnen also nicht so stark
nur abhängig von russischem gas bin
dafür dass wir auch flüssiggas etwa aus
den vereinigten staaten und kanada
beziehen mittelfristig und wir müssen
all die preiskomponenten die der staat
bestimmt stichwort noch einmal eeg
umlage in den blick nehmen um sie zu
reduzieren da ist schon wieder die
zukunft aber wir haben ja ein ganzes
kanadischen kunden das ist das jahr
2022 und ich will noch mal
unterstreichen was katrin göring eckardt
gesagt hat heizkostenzuschuss für
wohngeldempfänger
bafög bezieher das ist ja bereits auf
den weg gebracht das kommt und wir
müssen jetzt die frage stellen was tun
wir für die menschen die arbeiten die
keine transferleistungen beziehen ist
man im leben genau sondern die im
gegenteil etwas abgeben von ihrer arbeit
die dürfen wir auch nicht alleine lassen
und darüber müssen wir jetzt ein
gespräch fragen jedoch mal die frau die
mit den verbrauchern zu tun hat vollmann
was würden sie sagen hilft den menschen
jetzt am meisten ja einmal ist es
natürlich so dass natürlich auch der
fiskus daran verdient dass die
strompreise so gestiegen sind das heißt
man könnte wirklich über steuersenkungen
beim strom stromsteuer oder auch bei der
mehrwertsteuer auf den strom nachdenken
das würde erstmal allen helfen als
verbraucherschützerin sage ich dann
natürlich auch alle einkommensschwachen
transferleistungsempfänger aber auch die
die knapp drüber sind brauchen deutlich
noch mehr die müssen wir stärker
unterstützen eine alleinerziehende
mutter mit zwei kindern braucht mehr
unterstützung als wir alle da reicht aus
meiner sicht auch der jetzige
beschlossene heizkostenzuschuss noch
nicht aus mehr wäre wünschenswert und
wir müssen vor allem an die denken die
immer knapp drüber sind die fallen gerne
durchs raster und das ist gefährlich sie
würden beim heizkosten
den zuschlag 500 euro sorgen weil nur
das auch eine vierköpfige familie
ausstatten würde und sie plädieren für
eine senkung der stromsteuer das sind ja
immerhin 40 prozent des strompreises
genau dann fragen wir das doch mal ist
das eine variante herr merz zu sagen auf
der einen seite wir müssen wirklich
dafür sorgen dass die leute nicht ins
minus kommen wegen dieser strompreise
die jetzt am markt herrschen und zum
zweiten wir brauchen tatsächlich ein
angebot im energiemarkt der für alle
beteiligten auch der punkt wir reden
nicht nur über die sozial schwachen die
muss man selbst wahrscheinlich zuerst
reden um denen zu helfen aber wir haben
ja hier auch schon wie in ihrer
eröffnung über die ganz normalen
durchschnittlich verdienenden familien
gesprochen und da können wir eine zahl
nennen das was wir in diesem jahr
inflation haben wird wahrscheinlich für
eine durchschnittlich verdienende
familien in deutschland 2000 euro
weniger einkommen bedeuten so und das
sind zahlen die sind erheblich dass ist
der sommerurlaub für viele familien also
an der stelle würde ich dringend raten
etwas zu tun und vor allem man hat an
einen punkt angesprochen der natürlich
völlig richtig ist der staat verdient ja
an den steigenden kosten für die
familien für die betriebe durch den
mehrwert schafft verdient an der
inflation weil die mehrwertsteuer kommt
auf alles oben drauf also wenn sie alles
zusammen addiert haben kommt über alles
nochmal die mehrwertsteuer obendrauf und
an der mehrwertsteuer verdient zurzeit
der fiskus der bund die länder die
gemeinden erheblich da könnte da ist
spielraum bei ganz knappen kassen das
ist eine für den finanzminister
außergewöhnlich schwierige lage nur um
da jetzt schnell raus zu helfen würde
ich dringend raten sowohl bei der
pendlerpauschale etwas zu tun als auch
möglicherweise die mehrwertsteuer noch
einmal in den blick zu nehmen jedenfalls
kurzfristig für das jahr 2022 könnte man
was tun wir haben das thema mit der
mehrwertsteuer schon mal gehabt bei der
pandemie das ist alles nicht sehr schön
und ordnungspolitisch eigentlich sauber
aber es würde jedenfalls im augenblick
den familien aber natürlich wenn ich
dazu was was sagen darf die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion hat das ja
auch beantragt
stromsteuer reduzieren mehrwertsteuer 7
prozent bei der energie das sind
zusammengenommen
6,2 plus 9 milliarden 15 milliarden euro
da muss man natürlich zunächst einmal
fragen woher kommt also leicht ist es zu
beantragen man soll etwas entlasten
danach ist dann die frage will die cdu
höhere schulden machen wo spart sie denn
es ist bei der umsatzsteuer nicht so das
ist automatisch zu höheren einnahmen
beim staat kommt denn die familie die
mehr zahlen muss für energie spart in
der regel an einer anderen stelle die
verzichtet eben auf den sommerurlaub und
da entgeht dann auch oder sehr recht so
als auch da wo der staat verdient das
ist die sogenannte kalte progression
also menschen die bei auch einer
gehaltserhöhung
obwohl sie gar nicht mehr kaufkraft
aufgrund der inflation haben in der
steuerprogression nach oben rutschen da
verdient der staat und das ist ein
problem die inflation die wir in diesem
jahr haben ist in der vergangenheit
unterschätzt worden deshalb stimmt unser
steuersystem gegenwärtig nicht und das
muss verändert werden und da hoffe ich
auch sehr auf die unterstützung der
augenblicklich gegenwärtigen opposition
im bundestag die ja in den ländern mit
regiert da würde es auch auf cdu csu
ankommen im bundesrat zu ermöglichen
dass wir da die mit händler so und da
ist aber noch mal eine nachfrage erlaubt
talenten sie haben bisher in interviews
gesagt dass sie an den fairen vorschlag
machen werden wie und wann diese kalte
progression dann mit hilfe von
hoffentlich allen den an die menschen
zurück kommt weil es geht ja darum einen
reallohnverlust auszugleichen und dafür
zu sorgen dass die menschen sich was
leisten können was wäre denn ein fairer
vorschlag um zu vermeiden dass bei den
menschen nicht nur höhere preise sondern
auch ein sinken der reallohn ankommt wir
haben dazu ein klares verfahren seit
zehn jahren ist die bundesregierung
verpflichtet in im herbst alle zwei
jahre einen sogenannten
progressionsvorbehalt
2020 da ist die inflation unterschätzt
worden wir machen es jetzt für die jahre
23 und 24 da sind zwei dinge zu tun zum
einen das steuerfreie existenzminimum
muss angepasst werden und zum anderen
muss berücksichtigt werden wie
entwickeln sich die preise welche
auswirkungen hat das auf das
steuersystem da wird es einen vorschlag
geben ich will noch hinzufügen dass ja
auch der regelsatz der grundsicherung
vor dort werden muss auch der wird
regelmäßig an die preisentwicklung
angepasst und das alles kommt ohnehin
und da wird es einen fairen vorschlag
geben den ich jetzt noch nicht
vorwegnehmen kann bei den zahlen ja noch
nicht im einkauf kostet den kann man
schätzen auf einen betrag pro jahr von
ungefähr 6 milliarden der sechs
milliarden wäre 6,2 milliarden wäre die
für dieses jahr erwartete inflation von
3,1 prozent im steuertarif diese zahl
kann ich sozusagen amtlich besteht und
die wäre nicht besonders originell den
erwachsenen oder bleibenden hohen
inflation ist es natürlich mehr ich
komme ganz kurz frau rosbach noch mal
zurück auf diese frage nach den energien
und nach den energiepreisen weil da
haben wir noch keine so richtig gute
antwort es ist muss man noch mal sagen
politisch gewollt dass bestimmte
energien teurer werden das war ein
politisches ziel das ist hier auch schon
ausgesprochen worden und an diesem ziel
bleibt man natürlich auch die sollen
teurer werden aber sie sollen ja nicht
zu teuer werden also wann erlebt man
fest und wann weiß man ob etwas zu teuer
geworden ist die grünen haben von
zumutungen gesprochen die diese
energiewende auch bedeutend säubern sind
zumutung so gut also dass es ergibt sich
natürlich aus dieser gemengelage die wir
jetzt haben für die koalition
politisches problem weil preis hat ja
immer eine signalwirkung was teuer ist
dann verändert ich mein verhalten kauf
ich vielleicht was anderes oder ich
fahre weniger auto oder ich überleg mir
wenn diese jetzt dauerhaft so teuer ist
ob ich beim nächsten auto vielleicht ein
elektroauto nehme wenn der staat das
jetzt alles wegnehmen würde diese ganzen
preisspitzen ja oder zumindest sehr
stark wenn wir dieses signal wieder weg
und die eigentlich gewünschte
verhaltensänderungen die würde dann eben
nicht eintreten und es ist natürlich
schon so dass die idee war dass man auch
politisch über den co2 preis et cetera
eben die dinge verteuert von den mann
weg will so aber dass der spielraum ist
jetzt für viele leute einfach nicht mehr
da weshalb einerseits wird ausgeglichen
andererseits will man aber den co2 preis
erhöhen wenn man zum teil zurückgeben
über ein klima geld aber man kommt
natürlich trotzdem in der schwierige
situation herr lindner jetzt schon viele
dinge aufgezählt die er machen möchte
und die kosten alle irre viel geld
gleichzeitig will er dieses jahr nur 100
milliarden neuverschuldung zu lassen und
nächstes jahr zurückkehren zur
schuldenbremse ich glaube dann sind noch
zwölf milliarden drin und mit diesem
ganzen akuten maßnahmen die jetzt
notwendig werden ja weil die leute eben
nicht zurechtkommen mit diesen
preissteigerungen
verringert sich der gestaltungsspielraum
für die ampel und die ampel ist ja
zugeben ja
genau aber sie haben ja gerade im
bundestag gesagt das kabinett vibrieren
vor gestaltung
sehr geehrte r fährt halt jetzt sehr
sehr unangenehme grenzen die und wasser
ist ein politischer macht es wäre
besichtigen können irgendwann frau hat
ja zu recht gesagt die die frage ist was
gibt man zurück wenn man auf der einen
seite was verteuert und dieser
gewünschte effekt dass man um stellt
nicht nur im verkehr sondern auch in
anderen bereichen den brauchen wir und
zwar nicht nur weil es die grünen wollen
sondern weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht uns das
aufgegeben hat christian hat zu recht
ist das wollen eigentlich alle und sie
haben die frage der nächsten
generationen ja in den mittelpunkt
gestellt natürlich das ist genau die
frage vor der wir stehen ja vor der wir
stehen ob wir den nächsten generationen
eigentlich noch ein planeten
hinterlassen auf dem man auch leben kann
und deswegen ist es nicht wir reden
jetzt mal drüber geht es jetzt gerade
ist es ein kleines addon also den 80ern
war das so ne da hat man filter auf den
schornstein gebaut und hat gesagt dass
jetzt klimaschutz das können wir jetzt
nicht mehr machen jetzt müssen wir sagen
nee wir lassen erst mal gar nicht
irgendwas da oben raus pusten und
deswegen bin ich hier bin ich sehr dabei
wenn die verbraucherschützer jetzt sagen
denkt auch mal bitte an die die knapp
drüber sind und deswegen ist diese frage
des klima geldes natürlich ein
steuerungsinstrument wo man sagen kann
damit entlastet man alle das was wir
beim co2 preis drauf tun dazu geben wir
11 zurück und dann haben natürlich die
mit den geringeren einkommen da deutlich
mehr davon und das ist die das ist ein
weiteres instrument was sagt ja wir
gehen diesen weg gemeinsam wohlstand
lebt davon der wird vieles wird alles
viel viel teurer
wenn wir das jetzt nicht machen das
haben wir ja gesehen sind einsichtigen
wird gerade was wir jetzt haben vor der
inflation das ist das ergebnis der
letzten jahre eben fossiler energie
politik und das können wir nicht noch
mal machen wir können die nächste
schleife laufen und sagen wir machen
einfach weiter so denn weil sie immer
sagen aber dieses hier und wir haben ja
heute schon erneuerbar
die sind ja auch irrsinnig staatlich
finanziert würden und sie sorgen jetzt
erst mal gerade nicht dafür dass sich an
diesen märkten für die verbraucher etwas
denkt ich möchte frau erinnern vierfach
samen und so viel ich möchte kommen wir
auch noch mal zurück ich möchte frau
oelmann einmal noch mal in die runde
holen mit der frage was würden sie
denken geschieht eben am schlimmsten für
nochmals für die menschen die nicht
berechtigungs empfänger sind was kann
man jetzt tun um auch diese idee sich
ökologisch klug zu verhalten noch mit zu
platzieren oder sagen sie dafür hat
einfach niemand nerven der gerade eine
waschmaschine erneuern muss und nicht
weiß wie er das bezahlen soll ja der
druck ist wirklich hoch und das bedeutet
immer wir müssen alle mitnehmen
klimaschutz ist die die große aufgabe
für alle völlig egal wer in der
regierung ist das wird uns auch noch die
nächsten jahre jahrzehnte beschäftigen
es bedeutet aber immer guter klimaschutz
braucht guten verbraucherschutz wir
müssen das ganze sozial und fair
gestalten dass nicht alle gleich viel
zahlen können ist völlig klar wir haben
aber auch viele die mehr zahlen können
und mehr zahlen wollen und wir haben
auch viele die wir schützen müssen und
darauf muss immer geachtet werden an der
stelle dann danken dir an der stelle
apropos ganz herzlich nach bremen und
diskutieren hier weiter herr lindner wir
sind bei der frage noch mal bei der
frage wie wir dafür sorgen können dass
die menschen eben nicht das gefühl haben
mit einer zusätzlichen zumutung über den
monat kommen zu müssen oder schon gar
nicht mehr über den monat zu kommen wann
kommt dieses energie geld das ist gerade
angesprochen worden wer zahlt es aus
warum kommt die eeg umlage nicht bei den
menschen an es ist ein bunter strauß
nennt also noch wird ja die eeg umlage
gezahlt
hälfte geschafft sie ist schon einmal
jetzt reduziert worden und der plan war
bisher im jahr 2023 darauf zu verzichten
ich gehe davon aus dass es jetzt gelingt
zur jahresmitte zum ersten siebten diese
eeg-umlage abzuschaffen dann kommt
darauf an sicherzustellen dass das nicht
bei den
händlern beziehungsweise
energieversorgern bleibt sondern dass es
weitergegeben wird wäre übrigens auch
ein problem wenn man an stromsteuer oder
mehrwertsteuer herangeht wird das
tatsächlich weitergegeben und wenn man
es irgendwann wieder erhöht hat man den
nächsten inflationseffekte wir müssen
diese aktuelle debatte aber wenn ich das
vorschlagen darf trennen von der frage
der langfristigen energiepolitik denn
was wir gegenwärtig erleben das ist
nicht zuerst zum beispiel die
energiepolitik der neuen bundesregierung
denn da hat sich noch nicht so viel
verändert gegenüber ja ich würde aber
eher sagen ist es das internationale
umfeld wir haben ja in osteuropa
spannungen wir haben veränderungen der
gaslieferungen schon seit längerer zeit
aus russland wir sind sehr abhängig von
lieferungen aus russland deshalb ist in
einer mittelfristigen perspektive jetzt
ja auch anderes an schlussfolgerungen zu
ziehen als kurzfristig kurzfristig in
diesem jahr sprechen wir über die
maßnahmen die auch schon genannt worden
sie noch mehr energie geld des islams
die grünen das ist kein projekt der
grünen sondern wir nennen das klima
dividende bei den grünen hieß es glaube
ich energie geld jetzt denn das klima
geld oder wie auch immer als das aus
wann kommt der staat zahlt es aus und
zwar indem er das was er einnimmt aus
dem verkauf von co2 rechten dass das an
die menschen individuell zu haben wir
jetzt dran kommt dass man über wien wird
es ausgezahlt wir sind ja offensichtlich
auch immer noch streiten nein das ist
nicht streitig sondern das wird
gegenwärtig gerade
konzipiert dass gesetzgebung noch
arbeiten der ja auf der basis des
klimagesetzes der früheren
bundesregierung und jetzt in diesem jahr
wird es zwei
gesetzespakete geben einmal ein so
genanntes oster paket wie herr kollege
habeck es genannt hat und dann sollte es
im herbst noch einmal ein neues
sogenanntes
und dann gerne dass ich kenne das im
einzelnen auch noch nicht die
federführung liegt da und in diesem
zusammenhang werden wir auch darüber
sprechen aber das ist eben keine antwort
auf die akute situation jetzt wenn es
einen beitrag zur langfristigen
entwicklung so und jetzt haben wir
könnte man auch sagen herr merz frau
merkel und herr scholz gingen immer
davon aus apropos dass das russische gas
fließt es fließt nicht war auch das ein
irrtum der zu der verschärfung dieser
situation beigetragen 9 ist fließt ja
also russland erfüllt ja alle verträge
aber nur aber eben nur aber nur und kann
aber nur und das war ja sinn machen
party lernt noch leere und deswegen will
ich schon einmal ihr sagen wenn man der
meinung ist dass man durch verteuerung
der fossilen energien auf andere
energien ausweichen soll und muss dann
ist das gut gedacht aber dann müssen die
anderen energieträger aber auch das an
die nation darlegen
das problem wir steigen zurzeit aus den
fossilen oder wollen raus aus der
kernenergie sind war so gut wie raus uns
fehlen aber die alternativen und die das
ganze und das ganze bei stark steigenden
strommengen die in diesem land für die
ganze transformation gebraucht werden
dann haben sie jetzt schöne wort
atomenergie selbst noch mal in den mund
genommen allerdings die kernfusion wir
wissen so fertig kernspaltung sondern
auch einen versuchen kernforschung die
franzosen freuen sich und sagen es gibt
ja auch eine begründung sozusagen dank
der eu dürfen sie sich nun auch grünen
nennen weil die atomkraftwerke die
französischen atomkraftwerke grün
gerechnet werden also co2 berechnet
werden von der europäischen union haben
wir da also ein fehler
selbst wenn wir ein gemacht hätten das
ist völlig müssen
die entscheidungen sind 2011 getroffen
worden ich halte zumindestens die
reihenfolge für falsch aber das ist nun
alles entschieden das ist vergossene
milch darüber lange zu diskutieren wir
werden abhängiger von importen auch von
stromimporten und wir sehen dass wir die
leitungen auch die auf den ausbau der
netze nicht hinbekommen die koalition
hat vorher das ist im koalitionsvertrag
gut beschrieben auf legislative
entscheidung zu gehen also nicht mehr
die langen planfeststellungsverfahren zu
machen sondern schneller zu entscheiden
ich glaube wir stehen vor einem ganz
grundsätzlichen probleme in diesem land
unsere innovationsfähigkeit leidet wir
sind nicht nur zu langsam wir sind auch
in den einzelnen themen zu weit zurück
also wenn du sie uns zum beispiel mal
anschauen was wir im bereich von
erneuerbaren energien machen der
strombedarf steigt steil an und wir
kommen mit dem ausbau nicht hinterher
habe ich glaube ich noch nicht mal auf
der bundespressekonferenz sogar solche
schautafeln vorgezeigt wie da unten
dieser dieser bodensatz bleibt aber der
der bedarf steil ansteigt so und da muss
die koalition liefern und frau
göring-eckardt es ist gut und schön zu
sagen wir wollen dass von dieser
mechanik machen das ist die mechanik der
alten koalition darüber sind wir uns ja
auf ein nicht nur sie müssen dann in der
lage sein auch die energieerzeugung hier
im lande zu ermöglichen die wir dafür
brauchen und ganz offen gestanden bin
wenn wenn wir alle so weitermachen wie
gegenwärtig und das ist jetzt gar keine
parteipolitische schuldzuweisung wenn
dieses land diese weiterhin die cdu
jetzt der koalition kann
man wie wir da rauskommen aus dieser
letzten die aus dieser trägheit des
systems die frage hat auch eben leider
die neue koalition noch nicht
beantwortet sind drei monate im amt aber
da wird zeit dass es kommen also müssen
wir nicht in einer sache ehrlich machen
das hat friedrich merz gerade
angesprochen kritisch ich würde aber
sagen es ist ein beitrag dazu dass wir
uns ehrlich machen wenn wir es als eine
realität anerkennen deutschland wird ein
energie in portland bleibt bleiben er
sich wirklich nicht gelingen ihr nicht
immer einvernehmen zwischen grünen und
fdp in der frage wie ich einräumen muss
aber es wird aus meiner sicht sage ich
deshalb jetzt nicht gelingen dass
deutschland energieautark wird und wir
unsere gesamte energie versorgungs
indoors trump erreichen wir werden
importieren wie ich glaube wasserstoff
aus dem ausland ging gas aus den usa
flüssiggas aus den usa und kanada
friesischen atomstrom
wir werden ferner importieren sicherlich
auch synthetische
flüssig kraftstoffe die wir im auto oder
im flugzeug einsetzen und dann werden
wir viel erneuerbare energie in unserem
land haben solarenergie
offshore-windenergie und anderes mehr
das will ich nicht geringschätzen nur
als industrienationen werden wir mit
unserer natur raum den wir haben wir
haben nicht so viel wasserkraft wir
haben leider nicht so viele
sonnenstunden werden wir darauf
angewiesen sein weiter zu importieren da
müssen jetzt die voraussetzungen
geschaffen werden von
flüssiggasterminals angefangen bis hin
zu energie partnerschaft mit anderen
weltregionen ich will ganz kurz noch mal
zusammenfassen von rosenbach im grunde
sagen gerade die merkel regierung hat
die energiewende verschleppt und die
ampel lässt es jetzt den bürger bezahlt
ungefähr so ich musste ein bisschen
zusammenzucken als herr merz bei denen
strombedarf sprach weil also die
entdeckung dass der strombedarf sehr
viel größer sein wird als die vergangene
regierung sich das vorgestellt hat die
hat der der letzte wirtschaftsminister
relativ spät gemacht in seiner amtszeit
und das war ja herr altmaier von der cdu
und insofern also das kann man der neuen
regierung jetzt noch nicht vorwerfen
dass sie noch keinen hundertprozentigen
plan hat wie diese
stromlücke und dieser enorme strombedarf
im detail jetzt in den nächsten jahren
jahrzehnten gedeckt wird aber ja es ist
zu lange nichts passiert ist es zu lange
gelebt worden von den sprudelnden
steuereinnahmen ohne dass die
investitionen stattgefunden hätten die
nötig gewesen wären schön es hat man
konsumiert auch daran weil mich nur die
spd schuld sondern auch die union hatte
auch viele vorstellungen was man mit dem
geld machen kann und das muss jetzt
endlich nachgeholt werden aber
gleichzeitig wird das land ja jetzt zum
ersten mal seit sehr vielen jahren auch
wieder auf so ein finanz entzug gesetzt
ja also erstmal die kassen offen weil
die schweizer 0 war ein selbstläufer es
kam so viel geld rein dann waren sie
offen wegen der pandemie und jetzt
sollen sie halt langsam wieder zugemacht
werden und damit ich sehr gespannt wie
das funktionieren kalte progression war
in der zwischenzeit noch eine kleine
schleife die wir gedreht haben wir sind
noch mal bei der frage können menschen
die real 0,1 prozent glaube ich ist in
diesem jahr der realen runtergegangen
können menschen das teuer werden de und
teurer werden noch bezahlen mit diesem
vorschlag des bundesfinanzministers zur
kalten progression rechnen sie freudvoll
frau roßbach und gehen davon aus dass
das kommt also ich als bürgerin finde es
unanständig die kalte progression nicht
auszugleichen weil das ist natürlich
eine heimliche steuererhöhungen und wenn
der staat die steuern erhöhen möchte
dann soll das offen machen also dann
soll er seinen tarifverlauf anpassen
spitzensteuersatz erhöhen oder ja so
soll das offen machen aber dass der
staat daran verdient dass leute eine
kleine gehaltserhöhung bekommen die
sozusagen gerade nur die teuerung
ausgleich und dann rutschen sie in den
höheren steuertarif müssen mehr steuern
und haben am ende weniger geld zur
verfügung als vor ihrer gehaltserhöhung
das kann man niemandem erklären aber das
ist sehr teuer weiß die grünen sehen das
ein bisschen anders die hätten glaube
ich nichts gegen der heimliche
steuererhöhung aber wie herr linder das
verkaufen sollte seiner partei und
seinen anhängern wenn das nicht
ausgeglichen wird darauf was würde ich
mir auch gerne eine korrelation gesagt
wenn also die bundesregierung ist
verpflichtet dazu ein progression
bericht vorzulegen und einen vorschlag
und ich bin mal hinzufügen weil das ja
noch zukunftsmusik ist das kommt ja erst
noch das wird dann auch internet wochen
ist aber eins kann man schon sagen das
ist schon unsere verabredung wir werden
im nächsten jahr die beiträge zur
rentenversicherung voll steuerlich
abzugsfähig machen ja leider dazu
gezwungen wissen dass
2025 hat das gericht die politik
verpflichtet das zu tun wir machen das
aber bereits 23 und 24 ohne
verpflichtung und das ist nichts
geringes das sind zusammengenommen 5
milliarden euro entlastungen die in
jedem fall bereits von uns verabredet
sind man kann immer mehr fordern ich war
auch lange oppositionspolitiker deshalb
weil sie das geschäft läuft man muss ja
auch sehen was passiert und darüber
hinaus noch eine diskussion um andere
elemente geben katrin göring-eckardt
sprach vom kinderzuschlag einer
kindergrundsicherung ja wird es
vorschläge geben also das ist ja das
wird ja sozusagen als ende des jahres
anders sieht es im moment erstmal gar
nichts und sie haben schon recht die
frage ist ja macht man jetzt
irgendwelche pauschalen erleichterungen
oder sagt man man hilft denen die
wirklich unmittelbar hilfe brauchen und
darum geht es ja jetzt aktuell ich muss
aber sorry wenn ich darauf noch einmal
zurückkomme einmal noch was du der
energiefrage sagen weil es muss
natürlich darum gehen dass wir auf der
einen seite den höheren strombedarf
decken mit erneuerbaren energien
übrigens europäisch deswegen ist die
frage sind wir im portland ja oder nein
nach gestellt weil wir es merken wir
müssen es europäisch machen gemeinsam
und da ist der green deal ja nicht
umsonst ein thema wo der sagt wir müssen
auf die erneuerbaren energien kommen
weil sie günstiger sind und weil noch
mal das bundesverfassungsgericht uns da
auch gar keine der spielraum aber doch
erst einmal frauen eckert ist ja die
these dass ist die produkte verteuert so
werden wir parallel zwei systeme für
turner wir füttern ja nicht zwei systeme
sondern wir sagen mit eeg umlage mit dem
klima geld sagen wir wir machen den also
gleich noch einmal der ausgleich aber
die andere frage die sie alle wurden von
den zumutungen geredet und natürlich ist
es nicht einfacher märz hat ja recht
wenn wir die erneuerbaren energien in
deutschland ausbauen wollen ist es nicht
einfach wenn wir so schnell machen
wollen wie wir es jetzt machen müssen
weil es so lange nicht gemacht worden
ist ist es nicht einfach deswegen
brauchen wir schnellere
planungsverfahren und deswegen werden
wir da auch und da bin ich wieder beim
geld finanzmittel haben müssen um diese
investitionen zu tätigen wir werden die
fachkräfte brauchen auch nicht einfach
um diese investitionen zu tätigen also
so lange wie wir darüber geredet haben
dass deutschland kein einwanderungsland
ist sage ich nur jetzt brauchen wir
nicht nur einwanderer sondern wir
brauchen sehr viel mehr fachkräfte auch
in deutschland da wären wir viel tun
müssen dafür dass wir das alles wirklich
ich würde jetzt fast sagen auf die
straße bringen aber es ist ja nicht auf
die straße auf die dächer aufs feld
überall hin und deswegen gibt es einen
plan dafür wie man das macht zum
beispiel im ländlichen raum zu sagen die
felder werden sowohl für landwirtschaft
als auch für photovoltaik genutzt die
frage der offshore windparks wird
elementar sein die frage der
stromleitung wird element die hanseaten
noch nicht und wir brauchen sie und es
gibt einen großen strombedarf und dafür
brauchen wir geld ihr das geld zu
investieren ist zentral und deswegen
sind die entlass die wir jetzt machen
müssen so wichtig bei denen anzusiedeln
die sie jetzt wirklich in erster linie
brauchen natürlich ist das mit den
starken und den schwächeren schultern
auch ein thema was bleibt also ich will
jetzt nicht eine energie sendung daraus
machen aber es ist natürlich auch so
dass wir tatsächlich auch ökologische
firmen und energie gefördert haben und
damit die menschen überfordern weil wir
sie vielleicht überfordert haben und
weil nun auch zu wenig kontrolliert wird
ob die eigentlich ihre gewinne dann mal
zurückgeben und an eine gemeinschaft
zurückgeben aber wir kommen bleiben bei
den lehrern aber in definitiv immer am
meisten gefördert bei den fossilen
angefangen vom atom bis hin zu der frage
endlage wer bezahlt die ganzen spaß
eigentlich also da haben wir definitiv
immer mehr geld rein getan als bei den
leuten aber wir haben immer auch gesagt
das musste ich aussieht und
wie jetzt dann aber trotzdem die kurve
kriegen zu den finanziellen bedingungen
die erste und naheliegende frage ist
natürlich wenn es nun aus der pandemie
raus aus dieser welt marktsituation raus
milliardeninvestitionen der wirtschaften
gibt überall in der welt herr merz um
eben für einen wirtschaftlichen
aufschwung zu sorgen und wir haben auf
der anderen seite aber diesen mangel an
material an handwerkern an
logistik wird dass diese inflation nicht
sogar noch forcieren
in einem jahr schwierige ich habe eben
darauf hingewiesen dass wir auch ebenso
eine art lohn preis spirale ohne
tarifvertragsparteien sehen nicht durch
die abwerbung auch von vielen
arbeitnehmern jetzt in die it branche
die preise dort also die die lohnkosten
dort steigen massiv an und das verrückte
ist dass wir gleichzeitig arbeitsplätze
gefährden die in den traditionellen
industrien vorhanden sind tobias hat
heute abend in einer sendung im
saarländischen rundfunk darauf
hingewiesen für das industrieland
saarland sind arbeitsplätze gefährdet in
den traditionellen industrien wenn wir
diese ganze energiewende jetzt falsch
machen also zum beispiel in der
automobilindustrie
wenn wir einseitig auf elektromobilität
gehen was wir für falsch halten dann
gefährden wir arbeitsplätze in der
industrie die wir in zehn und 20 jahren
noch dringend brauchen wenn wir heute
beschließen würden wir schaffen den
verbrenner ab dann gibt es genauso wie
übrigens bei der atomenergie der
entschluss ist 2011 gemacht worden von
dem tag an war klar dass deutschland da
nicht mehr raus kommt dagegen die
ingenieure verloren da wird nicht mehr
ausgebildet sagen die betriebe okay dann
gehen wir raus also selbst wenn wir
jetzt hier alle einig werden wir würden
da wieder reingehen wir gehen da nicht
wieder rein das ist entschieden und das
wäre bei der genau bei der
elektromobilität so falsch zu sagen wir
schließen zu viel aus und da gehen uns
arbeitsplätze verloren und gleichzeitig
fehlen uns an anderer stelle die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer also
ich bin mit frau göring-eckardt einig
wir sind ich habe das immer gesagt
teilweise zum entsetzen seiner eigenen
parteifreunde
wir sind ein einwanderungsland immer
schon gewesen der ungeregelten
einwanderungen wir müssen jetzt ein
einwanderungsland der geregelten
einwanderung werden 150 bis 200 tausend
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer haben
wir nicht die brauchen wir aber bitte in
den arbeitsmarkt und in die
sozialsysteme das heißt wir haben nicht
nur eine materialknappheit und eine
arbeitskraft knappheit noch mal der
gedanke von vorhin da ist er schon
ausgesprochen worden wenn wir in diese
situation hinein jetzt auch noch
wirtschaft ankurbeln wollen dann haben
doch all diese fehlenden
deswegen wollte ich sagen der nächste
punkt ist wer investiert eigentlich in
diese transformation sind ist dass der
staat oder sind das die privaten
unternehmen
der staat würde sich damit hoffnungslos
überfordern das wird nicht gelingen das
kann man mit anschubfinanzierungen
machen und und und aber am ende des
tages brauchen wir für diese
transformation über deren notwendigkeit
es kein staat gibt für diese
transformation brauchen wir in großem
umfang privates kapital das ist da die
entscheidende frage ist kommt es in
deutschland auch tatsächlich an wird es
in deutschland investiert jetzt sage ich
ihnen mal ein beispiel wenn wir nicht in
italien gesetzgebung in der europäischen
union sehen die in deutschland noch
getoppt wird auf die deutschen
unternehmen der chemischen industrie die
hier 20 prozent der chemikalie nicht
mehr möglich machen dann können sie von
den unternehmen nicht erwarten dass sie
diese transformation bezahlen also ich
will damit sagen wir müssen etwas
breiter schauen wir müssen etwas
intensiver genau die rahmenbedingungen
betrachten wie wir eine solche
transformation hin bekommen und unsere
antwort auf meine persönliche ist ohne
eine mobilisierung in großem umfang von
privatem geld aus den unternehmen der
deutschen wirtschaft und industrie mit
den arbeitnehmenden gesagt er habe einen
größeren klassen nicht geben es war herr
huber wird es interessante diskussionen
in der koalition noch geben rechts
vermutlich sind christian lindner und
und ich uns da etwas mehr als katrin
göring eckardt und einige
sozialdemokraten jetzt mal nicht über
die mobilisierung sie nehmen mir nicht
kommen über die mobilisierung von
privatem kapital das ist etwas was ich
natürlich irgendwie gerade ich also was
sich auch wünschenswert in den nächsten
wochen jahren ergeben muss und ergeben
sollte die bleiben bitte noch mal bei
dieser jetzigen situation und der
inflationsgefahr danach wollte ich
eigentlich fragen die jetzige situation
gebiert oder schafft die nicht noch eine
größere inflationsgefahr wenn wir an so
vielen stellen in der welt ein manko
haben sowohl in bezug auf das material
das wir brauchen und so von als auch in
bezug auf die arbeitskräfte als auch in
bezug auf die energie gibt es also eine
gefahr dass diese inflation sogar noch
weiter geht frau roßbach und sich
verschärft oder ist es ein temporärer
effekt jetzt endlich meine frau sind
große investitionsprogramme aufzulegen
wenn knappheit herrscht an
arbeitskräften chips und zimmermann um
leugnen oder auch lithium ja dann sorgt
das natürlich für eine zusätzliche
preissteigerung dass es völlig klar
das heißt wenn ich dass diese
investitionen nicht stattfinden können
aber man muss sich halt klug überlegen
wann man in welche bereiche reingehen
mit welchen instrumenten also wenn ich
ihm weil er diese super abschreibung
machen die wird jetzt noch ein bisschen
verzögert ich glaube unter anderem auch
aus diesem grund ist es natürlich die
hoffnung dass sich diese marktlage auch
zum teil wieder ein bisschen beruhigt
also diese unterbrochenen lieferketten
durch corona die haben natürlich dazu
geführt dass danach alles um so stärker
angezogen ist auch die frachtraten sind
ja gigantisch teuer da wenn man aus dem
aus china was im container kommen lassen
will muss man heute als importeur auch
viel mehr dafür zahlen
das kann sich ja zum teil wieder ein
bisschen beruhigen aber rohstoffe sind
definitiv diverse rohstoffe sind knapp
und arbeitskräfte sind zunehmend auch
ein problem und da muss schon aufpassen
also da so große zum beispiel in eine
branche die sozusagen nicht mal den
privaten haushalt noch zeitnaher
bedienen kann mit großen staatlichen
investitionsprogrammen reinzugehen das
kann unter umständen die probleme eher
verschärfen als lösen und wie sehr
spielt da jetzt auch die position der
ezb hinein frost bach sich nun auch in
dieser spar und zinssituation
respektive in der inflations situation
neu aufzustellen wie groß ist da die
gefahr dass auch mit einer künftige
entscheidung der ezb sich dinge
verschaffen also die ezb hat ja lange
die position vertreten dass die
inflation die wir sehen
problematisch sei weil temporär und im
kern womöglich sogar noch zu niedrig und
da kann man jetzt beobachten dass die
äußerungen sich jetzt vorsichtig ein
bisschen in eine andere richtung bewegen
und das jetzt ein zinsschritt durch
alles vielleicht auch möglich wäre ende
des jahres oder dass man zumindest mann
aus den anleiheprogramm komplett
aussteigt es ist natürlich so auf den
finanzminister kommt natürlich das
problem zu dass er einerseits soll ja
eine gewisse expansive finanzpolitik
machen wenn es um investitionen geht
also nicht umsonst haben sie 60
milliarden an der schuldenbremse vorbei
in ihren fonds verschoben ich weiß sie
sehen das anders aber praktisch haben
sie es so gemacht damit praktisch nicht
na ja doch und das wird ja herr merz vor
dem bundesverfassungsgericht klären
lassen allerdings können sie ihre
verschiebung von 25 milliarden dann hab
ich gleich erklären lassen aber wollen
gibt es über in alle richtungen ja das
ist doch meine ich glaube deshalb bin
ich wieder eingeladen worden
aber die ezb jedenfalls diese
entwicklung in inflation weiter steigt
mit einer expansiven fiskalpolitik zu
begleiten ist natürlich relativ ist kann
das heißt die rückkehr zu mehr solidität
ist natürlich eigentlich der richtige
finanzpolitische schritt in zeiten
steigender inflation weil man die
inflation sonst anheizt als start und
weil aber die bundesregierung viele
vorhaben hat die im investiven natur
sind sie ist sie da in ein bisschen
schwierigen situation und kann ich nur
hoffen dass die ezb
das ist ja also ist die ezb unabhängig
also wenn ich das kurz sagen da
friedrich merz hat recht mit blick etwa
auf den verbrennungsmotor und anderes
mehr da müssen wir technologie offen
bleiben da setze ich auch auf die
unterstützung vor
also wir haben ja ein koalitionsvertrag
wollen stehtische kraftstoffe da ist
aber die union auch gefordert denn die
präsidentin der europäischen kommission
ist eine cdu-politikerin david delight
entscheidung getroffen also können wir
da zusammen wirken wird